I'm a big football fan I love football
football is fun
unless you have an alcoholic friend who
roots for a shitty team like the Browns
you know what I'm talking about those
guys are the worst you know those people
I've been in their house before they
start getting [__] up
and the Browns do what they do every
week they start getting [__] up
and what's happening next that house is
getting [__] up
I'm watching these videos of guys on
YouTube throw TVs off their balconies
what the [__] are you doing
like do you really think we would ever
encourage me to tear my house apart no
weed lays right next to me on the couch
Roots my favorite team's on
say [__] to me like hey Ryan you know
it'll be really nice around here
some holiday hand towels
oh hell yeah
hell yeah let's Spruce this place up a
bit
and weed ain't done there we'd like I
ain't talking about just Christmas and
[__] man
it's all about all the holidays oh you
know we're getting some Halloween hand
towels in here go get me some
jack-o-lanterns and candy corns hanging
off that of it
well get me a scared black cat
there's Mr good guy we he's like hey
let's not forget about our Jewish
friends man I'm like oh Hanukkah head
towels
I don't know where to get those but I
want to be festively appropriate God
damn it
and here comes that [__] alcohol you
know what alcohol would say to me
alcohol would say we're gonna wipe our
ass on those hand towels
and weed's ready for that weed's like
used to text
in your town September 29th and the 30th
get your tickets right now at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
[Applause]
funny show Brian was absolutely
hysterical he's just so authentic love
the show Ryan it was fantastic love the
podcast love the Honeydew podcast so
good to see you live but I know I gotta
sign up for the patreon you sign up for
a year you get over a month free
foreign